Captain America is a lot of things but
he's never been the coolest superhero
when the Marvel Cinematic Universe he's
quite literally a relic to a different
more innocent era and as such he is a
little corny but increasingly the movie
centering on him have evolved to be the
most interesting ones in the MCU that
trend continues and captain america
civil war which opens this weekend after
a botched rescue mission the Avengers
are asked to operate under the oversight
of the United Nations that sits well
with about half the Avengers but not the
other half creating a rift that pits
hero against hero and in caps case his
desire to do good at all times
translates into operating outside the
law if we sign this we surrender our
right to choose what if this panel sends
us somewhere we don't think we should go
what if there's somewhere we need to go
and they don't let us directors the
Russo brothers brought cap into
uncertain moral ground with 2014 the
winter soldier and they do a nice job
continuing that work here I'll be it on
a much bigger scale look so war is huge
it's not only the longest Marvel movie
to date but it brings together cap
specific characters like the winter
soldier with the rest of the Avengers
and for comic relief even ant-man look I
want to say I know you know a lot of
super people so thanks for thinking of
me most importantly though movie helps
Marvel pivot into its so-called phase
three which will finally tie up that
whole Infinity stone thing and to that
end civil war brings in a couple of a
new fan favorite characters chadwick
boseman has to cholla the Black Panther
and Tom Holland as spider-man while the
movie has maybe one more climax and it
actually needs it's on the whole a
really tight fun epic that propels the
Marvel Cinematic Universe forward while
being enjoyable in its own right so this
is what a rebuilding year looks like for
them things could be much much worse
you